I keep saying you know like we we were
born too late really to explore the
Earth's and we're too early to explore
space but we're just at the right time
to explore our brains and our minds and
VR is an amazing tool for that boom
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Saki on we are on
site at consciousness hackings awakened
future summit we are now speaking to
sarah hash this hello thank you so much
for coming on the show really invasion
of the word simulations nice very good
great congress Peschel e at the end
sarah is the co-founder of radix motion
and they're merging our realities with
VR and I just got I just tried their
product called mu and it was so cool and
embodied messenger platform I was just
basically in a state of we have a video
to embed here where I was being mirrored
my position in a virtual environment was
being mirrored by an avatar that was I
was constantly dancing with it and
mirroring with it but then there was all
this you can describe this really well
but all this cool pieces Sparkle motion
look it we'll get to this okay so who
are you what do you represent I guess I
represent a set of memes that you know
I've been lucky enough to collect and
there so some like get rid of others
filter right filtered set of memes
around neuroscience I come from a
cognitive neuroscience and a lot of
movement I've done martial arts my whole
life it's a really really big part of
helping me and being Who I am and having
all this like self-confidence to try
really strange things and combining
these these two loves I was like
movement and Technology and brains I
said became into VR as the most amazing
medium to create my own realities and
it's a god of my own world right
yeah yeah when I first took off mute
your your program I was just like what
am i doing back here I was just playing
God in this world like yeah yeah okay
okay so teaches about the cognitive
science and martial arts background so I
guess cognitive science aid in a
master's program Donders university I
was actually researching psychedelics
and that's I published a paper around
them the predictive coding framework
explaining what psychedelics does to
your brain if anybody's into any type of
brain hacking or meditation any type of
practice around this brain I highly
recommend reading a little bit about
predictive coding predictive coding of
coding can you teach us about that yeah
so predictive coding looks at your brain
as a prediction machine that it doesn't
have any access to the outside world
your brain right you don't know what's
out there
the only information your brain is
getting is coming from your sensory
inputs your eyes your ears but what is
actually happening according to
predictive coding is that this source of
information coming from your senses is
getting combined with your previous
knowledge right and that's sort of the
key part and what makes it sort of
different from other series is that
understanding this combination so even
when you're looking let's say a cat
you're not just seeing that cat you're
seeing all the cats that you've ever
seen before including all the emotional
experiences you've had with all of the
cats you're seeing before they're all
combining into your sense of perception
at that moment so you're in this whole
being in the now saying when we talk
about this or being present might be
reducing the previous knowledge that you
have of cats in order to just be present
with your sensory and for information
that's currently happening so there's
again this constant balance between
these two sources of information and you
can play with this in any type of
practice with meditation you can start
playing with again probably being
present more in reducing your priors and
your previous knowledge or you could do
the opposite right you
do the type of loving-kindness
meditation that goes into maybe these
loving memories that you have and
expands them and who recreates them and
helps strengthen these pathways in your
brain so there's various types of things
you can do once you start understanding
this framework and a lot of influence
framework goes around them this minimum
minimal self how are we actually one
being there's 80 billion neurons and
there are more billions of cells going
on and yet we form a type of agent and
the series a it's based on statistical
correlation of these signals
so once signals get statistically
correlated the best explanation your
brain can come up with is like oh it's
coming from a1 one thing this one thing
and this is where the sense of self sort
of come from and you can really play
with it have you ever tried the rubber
hand experiment teach me what's the
rubber all right so I put a rubber hand
on top of your hand let's say let's I
can we can try it I won't really work
but let's say we do something like this
right and this is a rubber hand and I
touch you at the same time that I'm
touching my hand hey that feels really
weird already so it feels super weird
and what happens is your brain starts
believing that my hand is your hand
because oh I remember this video when
they added a crude with the little
daughter yep yeah so this is one way a
very simple way to show how plastic your
sense of self is if I can transplant a
fake rubber had then you think it's
yours right and with virtual reality we
can start playing with that so much we
have you know another experience we
built where you have tentacles instead
of arms we're working on having like a
tail so I can start really playing with
a sense of bodily self that you have and
let you be something else
I totally really started to feel like I
was not living in this world when I put
the headset on and I was playing you're
warmer you designed I hope it was a nice
world it was a very fun world yeah it
was a very fun world and okay so what is
it
maybe you felt you might not even notice
these things because they were pretty
subtle but your movements were
correlated to the visual so we're again
creating the statistical correlation for
your brain which makes it feel like it's
you and the visuals there are 10,000
little particles that sparkle and move
and change color so it's very visually
beautiful and with a lot a lot of data
coming into your brain and also the
music was Carly I don't know if you do
you notice that the music was sort of
changing as you add up a little bit so
when you move the beat changes based on
your movement so once again you're
feeling that even though music becomes
part of you okay okay so even okay pre
preview let's let some okay so I'm
totally with you on on the cognitive
science that you um you you called this
again the predictive coding purgative
cordis addictive processing or Bayesian
grain there's a lot of grain so yeah cuz
we love talking about the the lineage of
ancestors before us that have provided
the insight that we have when we're born
and then of course in the immediate
indoctrination into all the words that
we use to describe civilization so that
we have this cohesive language where we
can say chair yeah and then this is and
then so being able to then do something
like identify a something that's
completely novel like can I bring myself
so in the present moment that I forget
all of the chairs in the past yeah and
that I look at the chair and I'm like
wow and then you really feel oh yeah
you're what what what yeah you think
about the would you think about the
cloth what no what is in what is this
even right would be so on
damn that's really raw in present yeah
without any yeah so stuff like that so
then usually sometimes people can only
get there maybe if they spend that
really long time in VR really long time
meditation a really deep psychedelic
experience but if you can train yourself
to always have that all mentality you
can pro
we also maybe live healthier and more
you could definitely be younger from the
brain perspective you can definitely
create this plasticity and childlike
behavior there's these are this is
basically what differentiate as we grow
older we get more of these boxes because
we learned more right and a lot of the
times this learning is reducing our
entropy it's reducing our entropic state
in the brain and children if we want to
be like children again and keep learning
then we should we can actually trick our
brain into being young again in many
ways damn and VR does that really well
yeah yeah it definitely has the
capability to do that whoa
yeah that's so interesting okay okay so
alright but now I'm the martial arts
side of things okay so teach us about
that teach you martial arts
okay martial arts is all about
maximizing the amount of force you can
create in the outside world right and
I'm not a very big human but if you
learn how to take all of this body
connected to the ground and create very
accurate vectors this direction that
direction you can create a lot of force
in the world and that's very empowering
if you can do we mean like huh like type
you know do we mean like a you know
punch break elbow with it we're never
sure hunt right taking the hard parts of
my body against somebody's soft parts
this oh wow the heart will do what are
the hard parts of our body I like how
you said you find the center and you
ground that and then move it in a vector
yeah okay but what are the hardens yes
the hard parts of your body usually this
would be one of the hardest parts your
heat your heel right the bone of your
heel is very hard all those edges are
very hard some people's heads here are
very hard depending and again we're all
we are different bodies but yeah
basically any any bone that's wide and
has structural integrity is the hard
parts of your body knows not so much
anyway
were you what were you learning this for
I was learning this because it was fun
and empowering and gave me a amazing set
of tools to feel I have the ability to
say no you know some things that a lot
of women unfortunately don't have the
privilege to be exposed to at a young
age disability to set boundaries this is
my world
it gave me a lot from a very young age
and I'm very grateful for my dad and for
my martial arts teacher to give me these
set of tools and the very safe up and
playful way right and the very
non-judgmental way cuz I was not
coordinated I wasn't very you know
falling over myself most of the time but
I stuck to it because it gave me so much
and because it gave me her so my teacher
was very amazing he was a teacher or so
and the wider you know word of being a
teacher and he was probably the first
person ever that told me don't listen to
everything I tell you test test
that's great you know I come from this
long tradition this is what I was told
this is what I think is correct the test
yeah these things that I've did these
tools that I give you and that's
probably the reason why I chose to
follow him versus other teachers that
were trying to indoctrinate me from a
very young age which is what most
education does to you do this because we
told you to which didn't sit well with
me versus test except for yourself you
be the scientist what works maybe this
won't work for your body type right yeah
certain tools may work really well for
certain people but exposure to those
tools that he often equality of exposure
to tools is so so important to see and
that people will play and find out what
brings the meaning that's a good thing
so then okay well now where was this
third piece to the puzzle this desire to
get into virtual reality computer
science programming in unity etc yeah
honestly it was just the most practical
tool that
countess scale scale things around body
knowledge scale things around hacking
the brain like I said I was doing
research into psychedelics but it's
still extremely regulated I was in the
Netherlands so it's you know not illegal
there but it's still very hard to do any
type of research you can't really do any
business around this versus virtual
reality it is accessible and so I
decided to pivot into that and start
creating my own worlds with that yeah
okay so then what was the what was the
quick bit in psychedelics before because
that has a lot to do it
yeah yeah awaken futures and also what
you're working on - yeah so again my
research into psychedelics was taking
this predictive coding framework that
we've talked about and looking at all
the research that was done in
psychedelics and trying to fit some type
of model around what psychedelics does
to your brain come up write what
scientists do come up with a predictable
a hypothesis that's testable and then
hoping to test it with data so I think I
got to two-thirds of that I had a model
I had a predictable theory but I never
managed to get access to the actual data
so if there's PhD students out there
that want to test my theory please do
and the basic theory that I'm suggesting
is when you look at the receptors that
are getting activated they're called the
5-htt to a receptors right that
psychedelics activate this is the
classical psychedelics I'm not talking
about ketamine or MDMA there was a total
different different stories so things
like psilocybin LSD 2cb those type of
classes of drugs they're activating
within the 5-ht to a receptor when we
look at where that receptor is sitting
within these neural circuits that we
have we see that it's sitting according
to the predictive coding framework on
the top down on the priors so on these
memories of what a chair is on the model
that you've previously created
and it's making them hypersensitive so
they're being activated at lower
thresholds okay what what does that
basically mean is that if usually when
you think of a chair this top-down
framework is very wide it's a
conglomerate of many of these different
memories all come together and this very
inaccurate top-down model psychedelics
is lowering the threshold and creating
competing models so you might get
various different types of chairs that
are much more accurate and much more
precise based on specific different
memories that you've had or different
experiences and that's really changing
the whole balance in your brain so now
you're starting to think and much more
narrow and detailed predictions and none
of these predictions is really enough to
turn off all the information that's
coming from your senses right this whole
predictive coding model means the
information coming from your senses it's
constantly coming up versus these
top-down predictions that are trying to
turn it off actually and only what isn't
explained gets moved on and to higher
and higher brain areas so basically your
brain is a little bit in a state of
overwhelm the prediction error it's in
the state of overwhelming surprise when
you're in psychedelic so it's probably
anybody who's tried might agree right
here as I grow so much so maybe it's
that this chair maybe looks like a chair
icon now and the door and carpet look
like carpet icons and door icons because
they just I'm not don't care so much to
distinguish between things no in your
usual
yes exactly I may be double-click deeper
when I'm in a psychedelic all right
where did this why is this metal shaped
this way who designed it this way where
did it come from why is the carpet like
this it's a nice metaphor I like giving
people is that our perception is a lot
like building sandcastles right the sand
is the incoming information that's
constantly coming in to us and we have
buckets we put up these buckets on top
of the sand and we build castles this is
our reality and psychedelic basically
takes these big buckets
terms if it turns them into smaller
buckets which lets you build a more
detailed model of your reality right of
your sandcastle of your sandcastle yeah
but they're smaller buckets or you're
gonna cut over well that's like the
waterfall that happens yeah yeah right
so and then your rain comes up with all
these mechanisms to deal with this
overwhelming flow of sand in order to
not not get overwhelmed it starts
rerouting this information and that's
what we see when we start looking into
the research and neuroscience when we're
looking at brain scans and EEG scans
we're starting to see other areas of
your brain activating and taking over
other parts of the brain that usually
don't deal with this type of information
so your visual input might start
actually taking over what you're hearing
and you get all these synesthesia
effects right the music might change and
you're your first you also change so
this is one of the reasons yeah you
definitely hit Sara up yeah you're sure
read the paper if your your email is
your first name dot last name at the
company site first yep exactly
okay cool and it's radix motion motion
dot-com come yeah okay so first name dot
last name at radix motion comm okay
because maybe it can be yeah maybe some
people can help move this yeah I would
love this to be I came up with a very
specific this is what your brainwave
should look like if the theory is
correct like if you test this we should
be able to see this difference that
happens between the top-down and
bottom-up but I never managed to get the
data so yeah so then this combination
between that martial arts psychedelics
and now the virtual reality how did you
end up being like okay I'm gonna self
teach myself unity I have
these ideas that I want to build tell us
about that journey I finished my my
master's program and my professor was
like so you're very creative they're
like yeah don't worry I'm not staying in
university for now universities are slow
I needed to open the first virtual
reality lab right they had an oculus
sitting in a box but for exam four true
reality was still like three screens
because this is how they've done
research for the last ten years and
moving things forward is uh requires a
lot of bureaucracy and is very slow and
I wanted to just take all this knowledge
that I gained and just start playing
with it yeah
please playing is the most fun we can
have and unity honestly is one of the
best tools out there to start playing
with your ideas and for a year me and my
co-founder we just had this project
every two weeks we would make a new
prototype Wow and there it's that's
still out there on their virtual bytes
if anybody it's all open source you can
download all the packages that we've
made things from just having wings and
flying flying by flapping your hand
right into things like having gravity
change and creating a gravity simulator
to try to teach you gravity to having
like fractals move with your movements
any type of a crazy idea we could come
up with we just like let's try it
how does it feel what why don't you just
give us a quick teach us a quick bit
about what exactly is happening when
you're when you're wearing one of the
like a virtual reality headset plus
you're holding what are these called the
controllers when you're holding the
controllers as well and what you what
you're like if you're in the game that
you built where you're flying mm-hmm how
are their how is the sensing happening
to where I go down well first of all
let's start there how's the sensing
happening so these there's different
types of headsets and different types of
hardware but basically there are motion
sensors
they're both gyroscopes that gives you
rotation and there's cameras or there's
again two different types of
one of them shoots infrared at your your
controllers and then reads them back to
sort of know where the position is and
the other is the opposite your
controllers are sending out infrared
light and they're getting picked up by
the sensors and the sensors are on the
headset nope the sensors only on the
very newest there's a new new headset
that's coming out at at end of the month
that will have the sensors on your
headset currently they're still
connected to your computer or to the
edges of the room yes to the room so you
have to set up right now at least one
sensing unit or multiple choose yes
that's true and that's and that's how
the and it's infrared yeah for detecting
in the gyroscopes yeah
infrared and gyroscopes okay now teach
us about in unity where you go okay then
if the controller goes down in the 3d
space right then beat the wings in a
game and go up great so there's a lot of
sort of preset packages depending on the
hardware that you're using that let you
read this motion control alright they
let you get the position and then you
can start looking at things like speed
acceleration and based on that you write
these algorithms that connect to an
animation right I can bring in and
that's also what's nice about unity is
that you can bring in these animations
that other people I'm not an artist my
co-founder is and create 3d artist but I
can't build any any thinks it looks good
you can import but you can import a lot
of them these things are for free and if
not they're very cheap like for a few
dollars I could just get an animation of
wings but I could decide if I'm
activating it right based on these
movements that I'm picking up and this
you do to code so yeah you just go tick
tick tick all right if the vector of
your velocity on the y-axis is equal to
something then move the wings with some
type of linear algebra um how much
you're moving a thing yeah there's a lot
of linear algebra and matrixes I studied
physics before cognitive neuroscience I
wasn't too afraid of that
so that's this is where I wanted to get
into the weeds a little bit and you just
did that which is that excellent and
unities free as well to learn yeah you
know there's a free it's free to learn
until you're like a big company so even
we got a little bit of funding it's so
to practice this is this is a great
practice as a great field to do things
like be the first and be the first to do
something in I'm kind of like being the
first on the moon or on Mars it's a
dress I keep saying you know like we we
were born too late really to explore the
earth and we're too early to explore
space but we're just at the right time
to explore our brains and our minds and
VR is an amazing tool for that way to
put it I love that okay all right okay
so let's let's wander now into you're
building out basically every two weeks
you're building on a new that was great
for you yeah that's a great way to you
know build up skills okay then the
moment came where you're like okay let's
do so they were of course a few pivoting
points but I was at a movement retreat
exactly a year ago right yep and we were
doing all these movement exercises and
the teacher there she Riga see if she's
called who's based in the bay she gives
so much visual input on how to move like
and that was so impactful and I really
realized like the arc this is the power
we are I can give you these
visualizations and help you move better
and give you these feedback loops so we
started pivoting more and more towards
like movement experiences things that we
can connect your visuals with your
movements and we started out with her
and can make healthy movement breaks for
the workplace so convinced you know
workplaces to have a VR station and get
workers to dance for five minutes a day
that's a great idea that's a great idea
but me and my co-founder aren't b2b
people Soviet right and this and doing
this sale it's a long sales like oh you
know and we part of it was we
realize that to get people to move the
social incentive is really important
yeah so as part of what we were building
there was a part where you would dance
and your friend would receive your dance
and could dance with you they could
follow your movements they could touch
you know your hands and you could do a
dance together and people really loved
that versus the exercises that we were
creating that still required a lot it's
very hard to teach people in VR without
another person actually being there
right you tell a person pick up your
hand do you know how many variations
you're gonna get people are gonna go
this this this this even if you put we
put like an animation in front of them a
3d to do the same with them they were
not doing the movements we wanted them
to do so we sort of decided for now that
to shelve that even though I still think
it's a great idea but it requires so
much more research and to take the
things that were working very well and
we're very fun which was the element of
dancing together and make it something
that is just accessible everywhere it
doesn't need to be just a b2b thing you
like yes people want to bring it to
their workplace great news and do these
dancing things and and mostly it's
really important to us to offer an
alternative to all the violent games out
there and you know like I do martial
arts I violence as a game I play yeah
but I think there should be other
alternatives and and we are what I'm
mostly seeing is a lot a lot of shooter
games a lot of violent games and there's
so much more we can be doing with this
technology so that's a big part of
what's important for us a lot of
awareness expansion that's so possible
with this technology okay so then how
about was mu the first thing that you
guys decided that you want me was the
first thing we managed to get funding
for that's a big thing because the
moment we came get funding for we could
add more people on the team and actually
build it out to the level of a product
versus our prototypes that we were
playing with before okay so so now then
so the teams a couple people that yeah
it's a couple people on the team and
and now let's go ahead and drop in to
Mew so okay let's let's start talking
about Mew and we'll have these visuals
embedded as we discuss but now first of
all let's talk about how the vision for
the idea as well as what exactly you
hope that people take away from so we
had a prototype before we got some
funding but the moment we got some money
we invited the most talented people we
knew of some of which we were just
following on Twitter yeah one of them
was called Isaac Cohen khabib Oh
we literally bugged him like and he's
seen one of our prototypes before so he
was really actually excited to work with
us and we brought them this team a
crispies lee is another person that's
very she has an embodied realities
podcast and has done a lot a lot of
research into how to create
non-addictive healthy technology so we
brought her on to and we have a musician
Nico and another I'm just mentioning
everyone otherwise they'll shoot me at
Lee another amazing engineer that
created a lot of very embodied and
emotional experiences in VR too and my
co-founder Matt so we brought them onto
our two-day hackathon like guys this is
our prototype but you know you have so
much talent how can we get your input
what do we want to build together who
wants to do what discussing like
possibilities what can we do as a scope
of money that we had because you know we
are so care about workers we don't want
to like they're not slaves and what part
of part of might want like trying to
make a company is hard it's like not
something I thought I would do in my
life yes but trying to create a company
that the motivation from you is to try
to create a different type of culture
where people aren't slaves that where
they can bring their true creativity and
true passion and I think that would
create a much better product and are so
much better feedback loop into their
lives I don't want them to feel like
they they have to do something
because of the money this is personally
for me like up a mission I think we we
follow a similar paradigm and I think if
more people around the world followed
that paradigm of ideas going through
them and having a family mentality with
the with the global village in general
yeah I think we would get a lot further
yeah I think we'd have a lot less issues
around burnout and depression and yeah
creative ideas welcomed at the table
that's so that's a huge yeah so that's
basically what we did for again we
didn't have a lot of money so we have
like two days or we could like
brainstorm and this and that and what is
people sort of unique talents along with
these constrictions constructions can be
a great tool for creativity actually
there's yeah like some back totally um
and then we started building and you did
a hackathon that's a constriction yes
has been and then we started building
separately who is communicating and a
lot of github nightmare right like
sharing code bases is and then when
Isaac had a bit of a prototype who
actually when he lives in an amazing
house like in the forest somewhere so we
did another three day fast hackathon at
his place adapting and changing and
learning his system and sort of bringing
it all together and I mean we're still
developing and bug-fixing was the
process and then and then okay so then
what was and what were the discussions
around the vision what did you want to
achieve with this so we wanted to
achieve I have three points from the
sphere system head and two hands I
wanted to achieve something that is both
visually stunning the wow effect yeah
yeah and has an emotional connection
that you see and you're like you feel
something in you you and that then you
can send it right this is sort of the
backend the server side that we we built
out to be able to share these things for
me having just a lot of you know it can
be used or so as a creation tool
just there creating your memes and you
get them to your cellphone it's really
cool use this instead of bitmoji you
have your own bit mooji's that you made
it's super cool but for me I really
wanted the emotional connection to be
there when you receive one of these
things I wanted you to be able to touch
it I want you to be able to record your
family's movements like my dad lives
really far away he doesn't have your but
he's coming to visit me next week I'm
gonna record his hug and then it's mine
you know he can be in the other side of
the world asleep but if I really miss
him I can go in there and like receive
his hug or one of my partners like me
this really funny dance for me and if
I'm sad I go in there I can really
experience it much more than like a
video or 2d thing because I can I can
touch it I can interact with it and it
tricks my brain to feeling that he's
there with me for a little bit so that's
yeah so there's so much here yeah yeah
so so the way that there are such
interesting ways to do things like
potentially capture in like both mine
files of people as well as like doing
volumetric captures of people and then
doing things like in 3d space throwing
it on and hanging out with your mom or
your dad that may have even passed yep
that you yeah that you can do things
like like you said just when you're in a
state that you want to engage with
something that you find to be that
calming or your tranquil whatever maybe
that can take you of potentially out of
a depressing dangerous state yeah
there's so much interesting potentials
with this also okay within Mew you said
that you wanted something that was that
used the the head and the two arms that
was visually stunning that was
emotionally yeah you had the captivating
and also that was shareable and I like I
like those things together and actually
within the game immediately when I had
you call it mu the part of the
characters that yourself is it a
reflection what do you call that yeah we
called it the whole time you
okay so yeah your friend top it so this
this this immediate mirroring that you
get of yourself is very powerful first
of all it gives you that that even
though you guys created it I still feel
like that was a huge part yeah and so
and and it's in the learning curve is so
little because all I have to do is move
for there to be the instant feedback of
I am creating that's really powerful yet
okay and so then and so then it worked
really good good and and also you know
as you guys need we can help with you
know doing that b2b thing that yeah we
were we have we like helping people that
we believe in so so it's a for you guys
to actually be able to you know to take
this off with these powerful
testimonials are these powerful also
just larger organizations that believe
in you that one they're potentially
poised to be using in this kind of stuff
so okay then
not only is there that first emotional
connection and it's as simple as
movement to make it move but then you
have what did you call the the particle
10,000 yeah we got a particle system
that's simulation alright it's actually
being real-time simulated based on your
movements so and that's super cool
because the moment you explode the
velocity of your movements affects these
particles changes their color they
expand further away so all these very
crazy physics simulations that are
connected to your movements
that's my simulations ok so this is the
you question you call this like um is
this like a particle suit it's kind of
like a that's a good word we could call
it a particles do that well for her
let's call it a particle another
there's nature lair you have an avatar
skin layer and on top of this layer you
have your particle layer cool so there's
a particle layer on top of the Avatar
layer and then that particle layer is if
you're still it's still its but it still
has tiny bit of randomness a little bit
there's a lot of parameters we can play
where the user can play with there's a
hole right Ashley okay so then that
dashboard was also very cool so not only
are you started kind of like a fire yeah
so we have so that's another thing we
really brainstormed around a lot what do
we start with we have very few like we
couldn't we would love to give people a
hundred different templates or ten
different templates
although choice overload is a real
problem yeah so we didn't we actually
didn't want to choice of other people
but we wanted what were the two or three
basic filters that we could give people
to start out with and after a lot of
discussion and I think like again Chris
Beasley was very impactful on her
understanding of embodiment and we
really focused on these different body
sensations that we have and we went with
explosive and peaceful as the two first
sort of filters that you have in which
your movements and the sound and that
visuals are very very different but
potentially we would love to keep
building more and more of these
different types of filters that you
explore and communicate your sadness
your happiness various you know
different types of emotional states but
the simple ones really explode which we
did with a fire avatar and peaceful
which is like blue colors and rainbow
rainbow II blue yes yes yes okay so
that's yeah some more in in future is to
add different wastes a sense to have the
person's state that they're in and the
way they're expressing themselves change
the music change the visuals of the
particle suit etc within the the this is
I
this part to be really cool yes you
found a way to make it so that the more
that I exploded yeah faster that I moved
the more the particles layer just yeah
explodes and then when I move my hand
back it kind of like it comes back and
it's that parts so cool that you can
create with motion like that and then of
course there were the parts where I you
know where I came in really close to the
to the face you're a very brave a lot of
people don't do that really that was a
lot of people are like you were just
like immediately what do I want to get
so close yeah this is a big issue we
keep talking about it what are we doing
with these eyes currently it doesn't
it's just one mesh with particles
because I are in there some what's so
important that I almost don't really
know how to do them well right and I
don't want to give people a cop-out or a
thing that doesn't represent eyes like
human eyes are so impactful for us did I
feel if I can't give them well I might
as well not come in some ways I agree
with what you just said something cool
could be you know but not potentially
you know have any planets maybe yeah
potentially that's a cool idea could be
yeah yeah having different so we were
playing with like different different
types of sparks that come from your eyes
or something like that like the full
globe the full earth so no like white
like alright yeah just the full glow be
just what what gets people's awareness
expanded the most like yeah I look at
the eyes and I see the things are so was
eyes is that eye movement right and that
is very hard to give I mean impossible
to give accurately you know for now
until yeah we're getting to the next
next generation we're going to have
sensors that will tell us where people
are looking at but I think that the
slight danger and that is either they're
just staring at you
they feel somewhat uncomfortable but
then creating false blinks which is what
for instance the Facebook thing we are
avatars do they just blink whenever they
want to and then when you're actually
sort of taking your own selfies and your
avatars I'm linking your brain goes a
bit crazy and your eyes start blinking
because you see your mirrored self blink
but you're not blinking and again this
predict predictive coding thing says oh
two different senses are giving me
different information that can't be we
need to we need to get these senses
together so your brain you either break
break that immersiveness or your brain
actually starts blinking I start
blinking so you need to make it the real
surface so we need to make it yes so
generally the philosophy of what we're
building is we use the real data or we
don't use it at all we don't give people
false feedback we take the real data and
we expand we augment the feedback on it
but we don't fill in the gaps with noise
that's I don't want to give brains false
knowledge basically and you'll take
people out of the experience like I just
said that and it doesn't feel as real
and your whole thing is that you yeah
yeah
now now within the dashboard I really
like the dashboard a lot so so so when I
like there's a couple things happening
here you know I hit record so I'm
starting to do the social aspect to this
where I'm recording it so I can be
waving high I can be giving a hug I can
be going for easy whatever and then I'm
sending that myself and sending it to
other people they can save it it says
you're gonna relive it in the moment but
I'm also doing things like starting with
the spire which I really like and then
that that's like a gradient from
something like yellow to orange to red
or something like that and then then
there's the dashboard which is both
doing things like changing the colors of
the particle layer to something like
rainbow which was so fun to play with a
rainbow I love that as well but then
there's also the what is it the size
the particles right the size of the
particles there's the size of the whole
avatar which I'm not sure you played
with but you can turn yourself into a
god like a giant sculpture of 10 meters
that you are now interacting with and
scale for brains as Earth so it's very
impactful if something's big you're
immediately small it turns you back into
your child self more so there's a lot of
play you can do in that and there's or
so on these noise functions that we can
put on your skin that turn you into a
very abstract blobby or jerky so I don't
think you even get lots of different
types of parameters that you can explore
basically yeah yeah actually I saw at
the very beginning you had in the
loading you had what people sometimes
reference to us like non symbolic
geometry happening because then my brain
when I saw your basically what was a
massive rainbow of light of stuff that I
couldn't say was something yeah
I was like that's cool cuz now I'm not
labeling things immediately and so that
that was powerful so if you can yeah
also do things in the experience like
turn it's strange because you for the
mirror effect for me to still feel like
that avatar is like me Namir for it to
have a head arms a body I'm like yeah
that's cool because but then if it turns
into something that doesn't necessarily
look like a human
then maybe I what is it then maybe but
we want to give people the choice not to
turn so you can turn off your avatar and
just stay with the particles and then
you can expand the particles and then
you're just in a cloud of particles that
you're right it's not that does the
connections there run in some ways
deeper and stranger of this is still
giving you feedback it's still moving
but it's not a human anymore
you can't become what other things and
this is me and my co-founder we just
love doing we just put only the
particles and that's it we're like
10,000 fireflies before just dancing
they're turning our low-level brain into
10,000 fireflies and if that's not you
know it's really the closest ex
psychedelic experience with like no
drugs cost and then what are you guys
thinking now like what are the next
steps for you you know how do you
actually sustain a company like this so
how do you guys make money all this
stuff so first of all or we need to be
out there all right we're trying to get
our prototype out first into test users
and then onto the VR stores so people
can download them and really building a
community that wants to start exploring
and communicating with each other and
this new form of communication it is
it's a new language we don't want to be
the ones building it alone we want
people to build us so we can communicate
with each other and these very new and
strange ways so that's basically what
were our focus is like getting out there
get people to start playing with it and
then what are the major stores the steam
store steamin oculist innocuous stores
or so looking at you Robin who is there
so lecturing here so he's having some
type of platform for VR for
transformational uses so cool okay that
might be it and then and then do people
pay like 10 bucks or 15 so we want this
to be free as a messenger platform
especially at the first stage of that
it's and now we want just we want people
to have access to it and enjoy genome
users for users later on we're thinking
of we're having a type of gifting
economy in there so if you know your
friend really likes football or baseball
you can have these virtual items that
you can literally throw at your friend
okay and they can receive and become
part of their like toy chests of items
that they can digitally play with and
move with things that again are sort of
movement based or if we build a specific
avatars for instance we're I'm really
trying to get a tail that works
maybe microtransactions
for very specific filters and avatars
that people might want to explore and
we're still looking into avatar into
avenues of them connecting with
musicians and creators and dancers that
might want to use this as a platform for
their creation so right if you're you
want to make a music video that's
interactive and people can actually
dance with you wouldn't it be really
really cool to do that we're trying to
contact these types of artists and
musicians that might want to mm-hmm
yeah the social side of the platform is
you just cool that you guys launching it
off for free now where is the future of
all this technology heading the
cognitive science is the movement side
of it the psychedelic side the VR side
where are all these things converging
where do you see it going I think going
into letting people be strange
finally like letting go of a lot of
these social constricting norms that
most of us grew up with and letting them
connect on deeper levels of what is the
weird inside of you like so much of
social media is disastrous to our
well-being and to our feeling of
empowerment because we're forced into
looking cute and perfect all the time
writing this whole like selfie I need to
be happy and can only show happiness I
can only show my cute side and I would
really like this to be the platform that
releases us from this that lets us be
particles it lets us be fire that lets
us be weird jaggedy pain you know like
let us understand each other on that
level that's what I would hope for this
to become yeah that was so cool sorry
yeah I'm all about that I'm all about
weirdness eccentricity idiosyncrasies
being unleashed I'm
about that the tab unas that culture has
created that is inhibiting people's
creative expressions is nonsense and
it's harmful actually in the social
media culture that we have right now
yeah sometimes occasionally a you know
I'll post a photo of myself like you
know like that and I'll just be like
Billy that's right because I don't
subscribe to that
yeah and it's because it can entice
other people to want to take you know
post photos themselves and very weird or
looking yeah exactly yeah yeah there's a
good a lot of people are sharing to do
it and I I love that aspect to it if we
could use VR to unleash ourselves fully
in our most weird ways that's a that's a
great and share that that's that's a
great way to shatter some of those
taboos okay let's ask you a couple of
the questions that we asked on the way
out of the show the first one is are we
in a simulation so
my best estimate would be yes however I
think it's a type of physics based
simulation and we are the algae
consciousness is a manufactured algae
and a very large-scale simulation that
has nothing to do with us this is my my
perspective compact that a little more
for us okay
so quantum mechanics rate this it's if I
were to design a system that's doesn't
that's trying to minimize the amount of
data being used guess what I would only
make that system get actual points in
space and time if you check that correct
everything we know about quantum
mechanics is telling us that we have
these wave functions statistical wave
functions that don't actually collapse
into a decision until they're being
checked which for me is a very strong
indication that this is a simulation and
again a simulation on the lower levels
of quantum mechanics now the fact that
this simulation is somehow got life
where a the entropy managed to run
should take this energy from the Sun and
heat and molecules were created I think
this is a yeah this is the the algae
zero is magically created in the
simulation and so I don't think we are
the important part of the universe let's
put it this way I don't think this was a
simulation that was created for our
brains or something like that that I
think some simulation theories are into
that what is the point then points
there's there's many points the points
is what you choose to do with this a lot
of time you have zombies across is the
point of who four of the simulation
itself sure sure whatever creator you
know there was such a large amounts of
energy and going into whatever was
created that I there
I'm not going to delude myself that I
have the ability to understand sure sure
the rendering is fast expression when
you do things with VR and start to
create simulations yes
you're starting to realizing hmm okay
the mass this is yeah yeah yeah okay how
about the second question is what do you
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world can I be morbid oh you didn't do
it like my brain like the first thing
that comes out is death all right and
tell us why it's the first of all it's a
great equator of life right we're all
gonna die it's it's an ending and
there's something because you're the
final the finality of it I see is very
beautiful it's almost like a
mathematical singularity right we're all
gonna get to it this black hole and for
some reason my brain thinks oh that's
beautiful
I like that a lot - yeah I think I'm
curious you quickly hear your
perspective on this some some of us say
that the finality of life that we are
going to die to the that this is finite
that that is what gives us meaning to do
things in the eighty year period that we
have here otherwise what would would II
would are your thoughts about that I
think as long as you can keep your brain
young which some people stop doing that
when they're 20 then it doesn't have to
be there there doesn't have to be that
limitation so I wouldn't say that's the
motivating force for me I think it could
as long as there's novelty in the
universe and my brain stays young and
doesn't cut these giant buckets and
thinks oh I've seen everything I know
everything then you would find ways to
go on forever
loop's us all the way to what you said
yeah yeah
at the very beginning yeah with the sand
and and also with psychedelics correct
yeah yeah yeah
the smaller bucket to make both those
some good stuff this episode has been
great sir I really I really appreciate
you coming on the show and huge and also
huge shout-outs what you've been
building radix radix radix motion radix
motion can be found at radix motion calm
ra di x motion calm also check out the
other links below in the bio
to Sara as well check her work out and
also shout out to everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
that episode let us know your thoughts
with you and share your thoughts also
with your friends your co-workers
families online on social media about
what it's like merging our realities
with VR go and start talking about it
more and and try it yeah yeah actually
you get out to the VR and AR centers
that are near you as much as you can or
even the best bodies like people place
like that sometimes happens yeah yeah a
lot of a kohake
like Hawking hackerspaces have them if
you don't want them even like yeah just
reaching out to people nearby
yeah and just being like who has one
like let me get to use one as soon as
possible I totally agree with that be
the be the Dodds yeah I'd be the
designers it's it's crazy how cool that
part is about it also check out the
links in the bio to consciousness
hacking into simulation support the
artists entrepreneurs and organizations
around the world that you believe in and
lastly go and build the future manifest
your dreams into the world thank you
everyone for tuning in and we will see
you soon peace